the fact that I was autistic at getting
diagnosed was what helped me to which
was which helped me to heal really from
genders for it maybe not here wasn't the
right word but like it alleviated it as
I understood my autism because it just
explained it all and um
yeah so I was looking into
um when I found out that I had autism
when I got diagnosed I started looking
into the neuro science of it because
obviously autism is a neurodevelopmental
condition and so I started looking into
neurodevelopment
um I read this brilliant book by um
professor
Sir Simon Baron Cohen of Cambridge
University he's like the he's like the
world leading uh Authority on autism
really or one of them but he's also like
um world leaning in cognitive sex
differences so the way men and women's
Brains work differently so he's about
five minutes away from getting cancer
that's true enough yeah
um
so
I was reading his book he wrote a book
called The Essential difference which um
if it was brought out if it all brought
out 10 years ago probably would have
been to onto shreds but it was about I
think it's about 20 years old now but he
basically did Stills all of the
scientific literature on the differences
between the way men and women think into
this you know very readable book and I'd
recommend anyone to read it but um one
of the things that I learned in that
book
um was
um the differences between men and women
in terms of uh what's called empathy
empathizing and systematizing skill sets
and so like this is kind of this is just
putting the scientific label on what we
already know which is that generally
speaking the majority of men are more
interested in things and Concepts and
systems and like problem solving and
that and the majority of women are less
interested in that and more interested
in the kind of
um emotional side of life uh
relationship building and looking after
children nurturing building that kind of
thing and so yeah I think summed up
really it's the most men are more
interested in things and most women are
more interested in people and those
those are the bell curves and obviously
there's outliers which it will come back
to but anyway so
um
then I learn about
the extreme male brain theory of autism
because
the amazing thing that you know that you
know the combining his two fields of
autism and cognitive sex differences is
that if you look at the
uh brain of someone with autism
their brain is like an exaggerated
version of the male brain right so um
really high systematizing really low
empathizing
um and um
that's that's the same for men and women
I mean I've got a little graph that I
can put up but it shows the the
differences that you know you've got the
men and the women the the men are less
empathic and the women are more empathic
but they're quite similar and then down
the other end you've got
um really unempathic uh
men and women with autism anyway
um
obviously
to learn that the autistic brain
is like a male brain on crack
you know started
to answer my questions because I think
at that before that I'd
thought there was something wrong with
me you know like I was
I was deeply ashamed because I I felt
like a failure as a woman before which
was one of the reasons I ran away from
it because
I had such low levels of empathy I'm in
like the second percentile for
compassion
so you know 100 people in a room there's
like one person with less compassion
than me
um and that's way lower than the average
for a male um let alone a female and so
I'm a Christian as you well know the top
level quizo as you call me
and for me one of the really important
things to do is to love people and to to
be loving and and I think I again like
that's probably why I got involved with
feminism because at the time I was like
I want to fight I want to do the right
thing I want to make the world better
for women
um
but yeah so this
injunction to be loving was so important
to me but I didn't feel loving feelings
right because I didn't have these
compassionate empathic feelings and I
was surrounded particularly in the
church with loads of amazing
um compassionate like pastoral women
and they were just and I just felt
nothing you know
and so I felt really deeply ashamed of
that but then when I so I thought I was
defective I thought I was a failure
really as a woman and then when I
started learning about the extreme male
brain stuff I was like well
like I'm autistic I'm not I'm not you
know I realized that I was just
um I wasn't a man you know I realized
that I was a just a rarer type of woman
um and and that was the key really that
just unlocked everything you know
because I mean it was gradual it was
like the key turned and then the door
opened really slowly
um because I yeah I did move quite
slowly into appreciating that but it it
started to explain everything because I
was like well okay
um I don't need to
I I was I did try I went for a few years
of trying really hard to sort of
be what I thought a woman should be
um
in terms of I try some of it stood me in
good stead now in terms of like helping
people but I I took a lot of like
lessons and training and like pastoral
care and so like I can I know the right
things to do like if someone is in
distress or like I'm not you know if
someone is grieving or stuff so I I've
learned actually a lot of practical
skills it doesn't mean their feelings
there but anyway um another one of my
elders or you know pastors same thing at
church really helped me with that
because before I was diagnosed with
autism I went to him and I was saying
you know I I feel really bad because I
haven't got these loving feelings and I
want to be loving and I want to you know
you know following Jesus footsteps and
you know love people
um but I don't feel these feelings and
he said you know like um
he basically said
your
um perhaps you could be the one person
in a room where there's like a crisis
and everyone else is overwhelmed by
their emotions and you know you know but
you can be like see through it and you
know be like really
um
helpful in that situation and just use
your gifts and and
uh yeah that really helped me that
really stuck with me because I realized
that
the yeah I was
I was trying to you know I was trying to
be the opposite of what I was
um and now I see actually that
the love primarily isn't about feelings
um like any
parent knows or you know a parent but
you're a teacher um I think you
mentioned it once or twice
um and also isn't your mum from
Venezuela exactly yeah nailed it
um
yeah what was I say so you is it love
isn't necessary it's about actions I'm
guessing well not even necessarily like
you can this is a problem I think that
we really just
kind of messed up with over the last few
years that we we think to be loving to
someone is to just go along with
everything they want and
you know like if you're a loving parent
and your child wants like
chocolate like just before bedtime or
whatever you just say no you can't have
that and that's being loving in the
moment um and they feel like yo you hate
me or whatever like you want me to die
you know and but it's just like you
actually know what's best and what
you're doing is loving
foreign